-Thank you, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show"!
This is it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're here.
You made it. Thank you so much.
Let's get to the news and jokes.
Well, guys, it was a really
exciting day for the country,
as we finally received
what we've been waiting for
for nine months.
-A historic Monday as the first
doses of the coronavirus vaccine
are being administered
to healthcare workers
across this country.
-The very first dose
of Pfizer's vaccine
was administered to a nurse
working in Queens.
-Yep. The first COVID vaccine
in the U.S. has been given.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was a little less exciting
when the nurse was handed a bill
for 50 grand,
but still it was, overall...
What a moment for the country.
Right now,
enthusiasm for the vaccine
is somewhere between the new PS5
and the McRib.
It's that exciting.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, people all across
America are lining up for shots.
Normally when that happens
here in December,
we call it SantaCon.
[ Laughter ]
I read that the vaccine
needs to be stored
at ultra-cold temperatures,
around negative-100 degrees.
In response, UPS workers
looked at their shorts and said,
"Yeah, this seems like
more of a FedEx thing."
[ Laughter ]
But today was really special.
Usually if I want to see people
on TV who've gotten injections,
I have to watch Bravo.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, everybody is
excited about the vaccine.
Just take a look
at the Colorado governor,
Jared Polis, waiting for
his state's first shipment.
-Any minute now,
we're gonna hear a doorbell.
Is that --
That's not a doorbell.
That's a knock, but okay.
And then we're going to,
of course, let the vaccine in.
[ Bell rings ]
Oh! There we go!
[ Door motor whirring ]
This is the Pfizer vaccine,
arriving here in Colorado.
To end the pandemic.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbal crash ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It got awkward when
the delivery guy was like,
"Hemorrhoid cream
for Governor Polis?"
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys hear about this?
Yesterday, it came out
that White House staffers
would get the vaccine early.
But then Trump backtracked
and tweeted that they wouldn't.
Come on, just give it to them.
What's the difference?
There's only three people left
working in the White House
anyway.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Trump said his people
don't need
any special treatment.
Then he went back
to pardoning all of them.
[ Laughter ]
Some more news from Washington.
Government officials say
that Russians managed to hack
Homeland Security,
along with the U.S. Treasury
and Commerce departments.
Americans heard that and
they were like, "That's all?
Must've been Russia's
Bring Your Child to Work Day."
[ Laughter ]
I think Russia has hacked
just about everything there is.
I mean, what's next?
"We now access information from
Blockbuster Video database."
[ Laughter ]
"Why you rent 'Lethal Weapon'
six times in 1998?"
[ Laughter ]
Yep, they hacked
Homeland Security.
That's not a great sign
that our Homeland Security
needs a Homeland Security.
How did they hack
Homeland Security?
That's like ADT calling you
and being like,
"Someone broke in! Help!"
[ Laughter ]
Don't worry, though.
Today Trump appointed a new head
of Homeland Security --
Macaulay Culkin.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, here's
a big election story.
Today, members of
the Electoral College
officially cast their votes
for president.
Yeah, super exciting,
if you happened to miss
the 75 other times
Trump's lost the election.
[ Laughter ]
Changing gears here, I heard
about another sports team
that's decided
to change its name.
Watch this.
-A major turning point
for Cleveland's
Major League baseball team.
The franchise is expected
to drop "Indians,"
a nickname it's had since 1915.
-Yeah.
But this is weird.
They're now going to be called
the Cleveland Football Team.
[ Laughter ]
You know, when it comes
to baseball team names,
just play it safe
and name yourself after a bird
or a sock color.
[ Light laughter ]
No? Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Collectively, yeah.
Thank you.
Red sock, blue sock, blue bird?
Yeah.
Yeah, the team said
they just wanted to wait
for the right time,
which, for them,
was about five months
after everyone else did it.
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys,
Christmas is next week,
and out in California,
I heard that two undercover cops
have been dressing up
as Santa and his elf
to help catch shoplifters.
Yeah, nothing says
Christmas spirit
like watching Santa
Tase a shoplifter.
You know one cop was like,
"Why can't you be the elf?"
[ Laughter ]
"All right."
"I think we're about
the same height, same build."
[ Laughter ]
"I'm the elf?
Okay."
[ Laughter ]
"There's not assigned positions.
You know, we could always..."
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, yeah.
I understand.
You're Santa, though.
All right.
You're Santa, and I'm the elf.
Okay."
A Santa and an elf
fighting crime.
Come on.
How is that not a movie
starring The Rock
and Kevin Hart?
[ Laughter ]
Of course, Kevin would be Santa,
and The Rock would be the elf.
Whatever.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, the other day,
in Ukraine,
it got pretty icy outside,
and one woman
had a lot of trouble
on the sidewalk.
Watch this.
[ Laughter ]
No, look at the --
No!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my --
[ Cymbals crash ]
Yo.
That's basically
what it looks like
when Trump's lawyers
go to court.
[ Laughter ]
In Ukraine,
that's called the treadmill.
[ Laughter ]
Don't worry.
The woman is fine,
and she hopes to be home
by April.
Guys, a quick reminder.
I have this new
children's book out,
called "5 More Sleeps
'til Christmas."
Hold your applause to the e--
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hold the drums,
hold all the noise
until you really need
to get it out, you know?
But anyway, it's no big deal.
It's currently the number-one...
[ Laughter ]
..."New York Times" best-seller.
No big deal.
Anyways, we're doing
a very cool thing with Target
and FAO Schwarz this week.
So if you buy the book
at Target or target.com
now through Wednesday.
So today, tomorrow,
and Wednesday?
FAO Schwarz will donate a toy
to St. Jude
Children's Research Hospital.
So you get a book at Target,
you get a toy for a kid.
I appreciate those guys
doing that.
Guys, we have exactly
five shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time for that
beloved "Tonight Show"
tradition.
It's time for
"12 Days of Christmas Sweaters"!
-♪ 12 days
of Christmas sweaters ♪
♪ 5 days left ♪
-That is right.
Every show between now
and Christmas, we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a ravishing Christmas sweater
from the Countdown
to Christmas Cabinet.
That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, since there are
five shows left,
let's open door number 5.
I see that's a big door
right there.
Yes, that's the one.
Whoa, whoa, wait, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Holy moly.
That is something else.
That is --
That is subtle, I guess.
No, it's the opposite of subtle.
Wow.
That is a --
That is an upchuck of Christmas
is what it is.
[ Laughter ]
That's what the label says.
Let's see who is going home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone,
look at your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get
a drumroll, please?
[ Drumroll ]
2-2-6!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, come on down!
♪♪
Hello! Hello!
Nice to meet you.
What is your name,
and where are you from?
-Hi! I'm Masha, and I'm from
Providence, Rhode Island.
-Hey, Providence, Rhode Island!
That's what I'm talking about.
Do you have anything like this?
-I do not.
This is amazing.
-Yeah.
-Can I --
-It looks like
you are trying it on.
This is unbelievable.
You have to.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Yeah. It's so exciting.
Look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Are you kidding?
Are you joking me?
You look gorgeous.
All right, super model.
Thank you so much.
Congrats again.
Let's give
our audience member a --
[ Cheers and applause ]
We'll be right back
with Gal Gadot, everybody.
Come on back.
That was great!
You look fantastic.
♪♪